Salut, aujourd'hui on va parler du mouvement du regard.
J'ai eu du mal à faire le point avec mes yeux.
L'idée est de parler de la détection du mensonge et plus précisément d'une théorie en PNL
sur la direction du regard. Il y a une explication donnée pour chacun des mouvements du regard.
Vous en avez surement déjà entendu parler que ce soit sur ma chaîne ou ailleurs.
En fait, c'est pas si simple et il y a pas mal de précisions à apporter sur le sujet et du coup d'autres choses
sur lesquelles on pourrait faire un focus.
Vous connaissez forcément ce schéma en PNL qui interprête le mouvement du regard.
Ce schéma est remis en cause depuis quelques années. Il y a des études qui se sont faites sur le sujet.
Est-ce que tout est bon à prendre ou au contraire est-ce que tout est bon au contraire à jeter ? On va en parler.
J'ai vécu moi même personnellement le syndrome de l'horloge cassée durant quelques années.
Le syndrome de l'horloge cassée est une horloge qui serait, eumh ... une horloge qui serait, eumh ...
cassée, un petit peu mais c'est pas ça l'explication.
Disons qu'une horloge cassée, elle indique 2 fois par jour la bonne heure.
Donc si on regarde l'heure sur ces moments-là, sur ces 2 fois-là,
on va se dire " Bas elle marche très très bien cette horloge ! C'est quoi le problème ? "
Bas le problème, c'est que le reste du temps, elle ne fonctionne pas et donc dire qu'elle fonctionne est faux.
Et c'est le cas de la fameuse théorie en PNL sur les mouvements du regard,
théorie qui a même été remise en cause par les créateurs mêmes de la PNL
Et c'est le principe même des recherches.
C'est à dire qu'on remet en cause le principe même des choses.
Au fur et à mesure, on les réadapte, on en tire des conclusions bonnes d'un coté,
mauvaises de l'autre, au lieu de créer 2 clans de "oui c'est ça et c'est que ça!"
ou "c'est nul et ça ne fonctionne pas !"
Essayons de trouver ce qui est bon à garder et ce qui est bon à jeter.
Le premier problème est que l'analyse des mouvements du regard sont centrés uniquement sur l'individu
et ne prend pas le contexte c'est à dire est-ce qu'il y a une porte, est-ce qu'on est dans la rue, est-ce qu'il y a une fenêtre,
est-ce qu'il y a des gens qui passent, est-ce qu'il y a d'autres personnes dans la pièce, est-ce qu'il y a des problèmes de luminosité peut-être,
est-ce qu'on a réfléchi à l'état de la personne, si elle est mal à l'aise peut-être qu'elle va chercher un point de fuite avec son regard ...?
Tout le problème est là, on applique pas le principe de la BaseLine
Je vous en est déjà parlé et sur la chaîne et dans le livre, la BaseLine est de prendre tout le contexte
extérieur de la personne et aussi intérieur, émotionnellement, en compte.
Si la personne a un peu les yeux vers le bas c'est un signe de tristesse.
Si le regard fuit l'interlocuteur, ça peut être un signe de remord ou un signe de honte.
Si la personne détourne le regard, ça peut être un signe du dégoût surtout si on met ça en corrélation avec l'expression du dégoût.
Pensez également à la psychologie du mensonge, qu'un menteur a tendance à regarder la personne dans les yeux pour voir
si la personne est en train de gober son mensonge, de l'accepter.
Mais le regard fixe peut être aussi un signe de colère.
Et dans le cas du schéma basique du PNL les liens entre la réalité de ses explications
et les mouvements oculaires ont été largement démentis, je vous l'ai dit, même par les auteurs
mais il reste très ancré dans la croyance populaire.
Parce que c'est dur d’admettre qu'on s'est trompé, ça fait une dissonance cognitive, on aime pas ça.
Alors que des personnes se sont vraiment penchées sur le sujet comme Alain Brossard en 1992
qui avait fait tout un livre sur la psychologie du regard qui s'appelle : La Psychologie du Regard.
C'était pas compliqué. Je vous le recommande
mais encore une fois ça sert à rien de se positionner sur "Ok donc dans le mensonge les yeux, faut pas en prendre compte"
Il faut les prendre en compte. Il y a plein de choses à voir :
la fréquence des clignements des yeux, encore une fois ça ne vaut rien si on a pas la BaseLine
si on sait pas comment la personne se comporte la personne initialement.
La détection : c'est cumuler plein d'indices et voir si il y a une corrélation entre tout ces indices.
Et là, à ce moment-là, on ne sera pas encore sur à 100%
parce qu'il y a le mensonge verbal, de ce qui est raconté, il y a aussi le mensonge émotionnel :
dans quel état elle veut paraître et dans quel état elle est vraiment.
Mais quoi qu'il en soit, il n'existe pas de recette miracle en disant "si la personne fait ça, c'est qu'elle ment !"
Je vais terminer en vous parlant d'une étude intéressante et récente
qui date de 2012, qui a été faite par des chercheurs de l’université de Portsmouth.
Ils ont fait 2 protocoles expérimentaux.
La première expérience était dans un aéroport où ils ont demandé à 204 voyageurs où est-ce qu'ils allaient en voyage.
D’abord les gens devaient dire la vérité. Parfois ils devaient mentir.
Ils ont analysé ces données et par rapport au mouvement des regards prédis en PNL,
et les résultats sont très clairs : ils ne sont pas significatifs.
C'est à dire qu'il y avait tellement peu de différences, ça revenait à jouer une pièce pile ou face au hasard pour donner la réponse.
Dans la 2ème expérience un peu plus intéressante, il y a eu 31 personnes participantes
qui devaient dire quel métier elles faisaient et après elles devaient mentir en s’inventant un métier.
Sur ces 31 personnes, 10% des résultats aurait pu être prédis par les mouvements oculaires de la PNL.
10% là, c'est significatif mais c'est pas beaucoup.
En conclusion, moi je me range clairement du coté des études scientifiques
sur l'analyse globale du schéma de la PNL
qu'on peut prendre, froisser et jeter à la poubelle.
Mais attention en prenant en compte qu'il y a quand même beaucoup de choses à voir au niveau des yeux.
Par contre, comme on est sur cette chaîne, je me dis : pourquoi on se refait pas une expérience mentale
comme on l'a fait déjà 2 fois cette année ?
et ensuite je publie les résultats.
Alors encore une fois, on est pas dans un laboratoire ici donc je publie les résultats mais il valent ce qu'il valent.
On est pas sûr que vous, quand vous répondez, vous êtes pas déjà en train de mentir, on n'en sait rien.
A chaque fois que j'ai fait ça sur la chaîne, vous avez été 30 000, 40 000 une fois 50 000 à participer
donc c'est intéressant.
Je vous propose simplement de demander à une personne de votre entourage ce qu'elle fait dans la vie, de vous le raconter,
et vous notez quelle est la direction principale de son regard par rapport à elle.
C'est à dire est-ce que les yeux vont sur sa gauche ou sur sa droite
sans chercher à penser haut, bas etc ... et ensuite comme dans l'étude dont je vous ai parlé,
vous lui demandez de s'inventer un métier, de vous raconter ce métier qu'elle s’invente
et là aussi vous notez la direction du regard et cliquez dans la description.
Il y a un lien, un formulaire où vous pouvez mettre votre résultat.
J'analyserai toutes ces données et vous ferrai une vidéo retour là-dessus au mois de septembre,
courant septembre comme ça vous avez tout l'été pour faire ça.
Même si vous voulez le faire plusieurs fois à plusieurs personnes.
En parlant de cette été, il n'y aura pas d'autres dédicaces cet été du livre.
Les dédicaces reprendront à partir du mois de septembre. Je ne sais pas encore quand, je ne sais pas encore où.
J'ai vu un commentaire passer pas mal de fois, oui, si vous avez déjà le livre, je vous le dédicace quand même.
Il n'y a pas de soucis. Et si vous ne l'avez pas, Votre Cerveau est Extraordinaire,
il y a un lien sur une vidéo explicative sur le livre dans la description.
Et maintenant, qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Je vais vous le dire moi qu'est-ce qu'on fait.
On prend de quoi noter, on met un petit truc dans son agenda.
On se le marque en gros quelque part dans la maison
mais on prend rendez-vous là vous et moi, oui toi qui regarde cette vidéo.
Je vous donne rendez-vous pour la prochaine vidéo à 11h samedi matin.
Comme d'habitude, n'oubliez pas, vous pouvez mettre quelque chose en l'air
et merci de ne pas isoler cette phrase de son contexte
vous abonner si vous n’êtes pas abonné ou que youtube vous a désabonné de la chaîne
et rendez-vous samedi à 11h ! Ciao !